on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
TV tonight on PE organiz S one of the
world's most influential and
controversial intellectuals in his most
revealing interview yet Dr Jordan
Peterson one
[Music]
onone live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to Pi
Morgan uncensored Jordan Peterson is the
closest thing in the world to a rockstar
intellectual his books are overnight
Smash Hits Millions watch him online his
tours packed theaters and Arenas across
the world tomorrow I'll bring you Jordan
and his Superstar daughter Michaela
together for their first major interview
tonight though it's the big dog Jordan
Peterson
uncensored well I'm joined Again by by
Jordan Peterson Jordan it's been one
year can you believe that since you came
and sat in my studio and we had what was
an extraordinary uh interview got very
emotional uh one part of it uh a can you
believe it's a year and what kind of
reaction did you have to that interview
because some of the clips went so big
and everyone was having a view about it
what was your
reaction well I enjoyed talking to you
and I was um I'm never that happy really
when I become emotional about something
that's being discussed and sometimes for
me that's a consequence of not exactly
Optimal Health you know it makes me a
little bit more emotionally fragile than
I'd like to be but by the same token I I
wasn't unhappy with it I do still hold
to my belief that I am addressing um a
loss A demoralization among young people
and maybe particularly young men and
that I don't feel that there's anything
inappropriate about that and so we
touched on that and um I mean other than
that I was very happy I was very happy
overall with the interview and with the
re and with the manner in which people
received it I was too uh I had an
extraordinary reaction just in the
streets you know of London and New York
and people coming up to me wanting to
talk about it wanting to know what I
thought of you and it made me realize
just how wide your influence is and how
important you are to so many people
especially actually young men uh how do
you how do you feel about that influence
and power that you have through that
influence over so many young minds
well I hope it's not power you know
because power is not a good thing you
have to be a fool to want Power if it's
influence that's a good thing if it's an
Invitational influence that's a better
thing if it is um the sort of influence
that encourages people to stand up on
their own and to help them believe that
they can do that and that they should do
it and that the world is a lesser place
if they don't then that's a good thing
and and I do think that that's what's
happening I interviewed uh Steven Pinker
recently and he uh he'd always said for
years that we've never had it so good uh
as a planet that statistically whether
it was poverty or health or age or
whatever it may be that on almost every
recordable metric this is the best time
to ever be alive and I asked him whether
post the pandemic the war in Ukraine the
cost of living crisis around the world
did he still feel that that held true
and he said yes that actually despite
that this is the best time actually in
in many ways to ever be alive when I
read your Twitter feed which I find
fascinating exciting uh challenging
combative but often quite Furious I get
a sense of somebody quite angry with the
state of the world is that a fair
reflection of your state of mind about
the world if so why am I angry um no I
wouldn't say precisely so um I I'm upset
at many things that I see I think the
Net Zero move is is is a travesty in in
five different dimensions I'm absolutely
appalled that the globalist utopian
elitists would sacrifice the poor to
save the planet especially when there's
no evidence whatsoever that they're
actually effectively saving the planet
and we could take Germany as a case in
point there and I would say the UK to
some degree um but I'm I'm fundamentally
optimistic I think that people I think
that human beings can solve any problem
that's set in front of them this is also
another place where I think the
apocalyptic utopians have got something
seriously wrong like they basically take
a zero sum approach to to economic
analysis of the world we have finite
resources there's only room for a
certain number of people and so of
course that BS the question of what your
world you're going to do with all those
excess people and uh we have to you know
we have to move towards degrowth or
there's going to be an apocalypse and I
think everything about that set of
presuppositions is wrong we don't live
in a zero sum Universe the apocalyptic
outcome that everyone's predicting isn't
necessary and the more fundamental truth
of the matter is is that people if
people
adopt subsidiary responsibility and we
could get into what that means and we
organize our social hierarchies
effectively and generously we could make
the Desert Bloom we can make much out of
virtually nothing and and that's and
human beings have that capacity because
we can transform cognitively and there's
no reason to assume at all that we
couldn't have more than enough for
everyone now that would mean those who
want more for themselves than for other
people would have to let go of that
essentially power mad uh desire and be
willing to share and be willing to raise
the poor out of poverty and of course
doing so decreases the gap between rich
and poor and that's very annoying if
you're narcissistic and Rich
what's fascinating actually is that
whenever I've interviewed you or done
your podcast and I'm feeling it again
now I agree with so much of what you say
but that's not really the point I
believe that you come from a place of
authenticity and I think there are other
people like that Joe Rogan is another
one that I watch him I don't always
agree with him but I always feel he's
authentic uh in a different way and to a
lesser degree but I think the point's
the same someone like Andrew Tate I
could see why he resonates so much with
young men in particular because much of
what he said says they feel feels a void
in their lives where they feel oppressed
as a group of people and he gives them a
sense of empowerment so I get I get that
and it's interesting that I I cite the
three of you because Gavin Nome who's
the governor of California and many
think may end up being the Democrat
nominee for the presidency next year he
said this he said I have a very serious
conversation with my eldest daughter
about the chat bots on Snapchat I really
worry about the misinformation dis
information about what's happening with
our country but I really worry about
these micro Cults that my kids are in I
say micro Cults because I don't know if
there's a better way to describe it my
son is asking me about Andrew Tate
Jordan Peterson and then immediately
he's talking about Joe Rogan and I'm
like here it is the pathway and when I
read that I sort of laughed because I
thought what what pathway do you think
that is that Co statement was
unconsciously comical in four dimensions
which is pretty remarkable achievement
as far as I'm concerned I mean first of
all anybody who talks about
misinformation and
disinformation that the misinformation
and disinformation that other people are
spreading is they they immediately
invalidate themselves as a serious
observer in my uh Viewpoint because
they're they're basically arbitrary
sensors I mean it's not as if we have
some stellar and um completely
omniscient manner of distinguishing
truth from falsehood which is why we
have free speech so we can hash things
out and if people are foolish enough to
believe that there's some
straightforward way of identifying the
purveyors of Miss and disinformation
which is what the UN insists upon now
then they are in fact identifying
themselves as the prime purveyors of
such falsehood I would say then um the
micro called comment that's just
ridiculously funny because if you are
daed enough to think that Joe Rogan is a
micr cult you live in
1995 Joe Rogan is the most powerful
journalist who's ever lived by an by an
order of magnitude and if you don't know
that you're just not in the you're not
in the modern world and so and young
people are in the modern world and they
know that Joe Rogan isn't a micr cult
and Gavin Newsome might not know that
but that just means that he's he's
anachronistic enough to be duded so
that's pretty damn funny and then the
next part that's funny is that maybe if
Nome had a clue he'd be curious about
why his own children are interested in
these micr cults and and exactly what
what it is about let's say Tate and
Rogan and I that are grouped together
even though it's a strange grouping I
mean I'm not particularly happy to be
grouped with Andrew Tate because I think
that he there's some elements about what
he does that are quite reprehensible but
that we could certainly talk about that
um and so so you know there should be
some Curiosity on nome's front trying to
figure out why it is that this degree of
popularity exists and then the pathway
comment is also extremely comical I
tweeted out after that it's like well
yeah Gavin you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
we're going to turn your girls into
women and your boys into men and I know
that's a dreadful proposition but well
you know it's just so Preposterous I
don't know well I don't know who he
thinks he is in the most fundamental
sense and that's really something
crucial since he's likely going to run
for president right and I don't know
what world he thinks he lives in but he
certainly has virtually zero curiosity
you know and I should point out as well
Pierce I have invited many many many
many Democrats onto my podcast and one
has agreed and that's going to be
broadcast soon but for years I've worked
and I have very many contacts with
Democrats by the way they're all
terrified to come on my podcast they
won't talk to me and so if it is a micro
cult at least half the reason for that
is that the damn uh useful idiots on the
Progressive side let's say are too
terrified of the woke mob to come out
and have a
conversation on satday next Jordan
Peterson has spoken up for him battle
Russell Brand does he stand by
[Music]
it good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored
in New York City King pi and King Q I
think there's only room for one king you
know I'm saying he's mocked your weight
Trump yeah look at him fail St working
just cuz they're skin folk don't mean
they're kin folk do you believe you can
win this war they making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betray keep it
awardwinning Lucy Ley will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Ley once NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what 7
years down the line I mean it's it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the world so
was even more Unthinkable if this nurse
had misgendered somebody on a board
she'd have been out the door when they
first got together there were press
stories weighty ktie that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I he
wish I'd never met him the conservative
party can certainly win the next
election can we yes lab 29 Points
the did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on on
the visa application form and therefore
got it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
souls
[Music]
Let It
Roll if we stop producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off CHS
this some of them they're easily
LD you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you and we're
just asking patients to be patient with
us well I in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jurry I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
you be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk to TV is about you and your
opinions if you're thinking about it
we're talking about
it it's all about me a
[Music]
joke welcome back to uncensored my
exclusive interview with Jordan Peterson
in the next part of our conversation I
stopped by asking him what it's like
living in Canadian Prime Minister in
Justin Trudeau's woke
Paradise living in Justin Trudeau's
Canada it's a never it's a never ending
hallucinogenic surreal dream it ju
Justin Trudeau's mode of governance is
to top each scandal with a bigger
Scandal and he's really good at that and
you might say well what's wrong with
Canadians and I can tell you what's
wrong with Canadians is that Canadians
have a very difficult choice to make
they can either wake up and realize that
under the jurisdiction of this
Preposterous narcissist we've
compromised virtually every institution
of Integrity in Canada which is a really
bitter P to P pill to swallow or we can
assume that everyone who's pointing that
out is some sort of conspiracy theorist
and it's way easier for Canadians to
follow to swallow the latter story than
to actually contend with the true
ramifications of the former story now
unfortunately the former story is true
so
that's okay what is extraordinary what's
extraordinary I mean what's
extraordinary right now you've been
ordered don't even know if that's the
right word to use to take social media
training by a Canadian court because you
posted tweets criticizing the
transgender and body positivity
movements my first question is I do you
intend to do
this oh well I've got all sorts of evil
plans on that front I mean at the moment
we've appealed the decision of the court
in Canada to allow the college to
proceed with their re-education of me
now the
re-education um what are the criteria of
the re-education program is that I'm
required to sit down with a social media
expert whatever the hell that is because
that's not a genuine that's not a
genuine occupation I don't even know how
you define it and I'm supposed to also
as a clinician be very very careful
about how I allow myself to be educated
let's say I'm supposed to educate myself
according to the the tenants of
scientific investigation for example or
re
require recognized clinical practice and
social media expert doesn't fit into
those categories anyways I'm supposed to
sit down with a social media expert and
then I'm supposed to modify my attitude
however I'm supposed to do that until
they're satisfied that I've changed and
you know that's not that likely as far
as I can tell because I haven't changed
since I was 3 years old really in some
core elements Jordan it's all so
Preposterous isn't it I mean the idea
that in a modern democratic society
which Canada purports to be the idea
they take one of its great thinkers you
know clinical psychologist like you're
someone who literally is one of the
smarter thinkers and brains in the
country and think that they can get a
social media expert whatever that is to
re-educate you about views that you
honestly hold about some of the Insanity
of the gender debate or the insanity of
the body positivity debate the idea that
somehow you're in the wrong and you have
to be re-educated that in a way is a
form of fascism isn't it I mean it's a
kind of Nazism that someone like chudo
would profess to hate most in the world
and yet he's encouraging the
demonization of you for challenging the
insanity it's the world of evil clowns
man it's it's Preposterous in the
extreme
let me ask you about something else sort
of vaguely attached to it but the
Russell Brand Scandal for example raises
a number of issues you know I've felt
quite strongly for a while since the me
to times up campaigns came along not
that I had any objection to very bad
people getting their come up and good
I'm glad they have but the due process
was getting flatlined time after time uh
in these campaigns with with with
particular instances and this strikes me
as another one where Russ Russ bran has
been accused by a number of women
anonymously in most cases of serious
allegations rape and sexual assault and
so on he's vly denied them and yet he's
already being cancelled left right and
Center by corporations by politicians
trying to stop tech companies paying him
any money and so on and so on why are we
now doing this to people where they get
eviscerated destroyed cancelled ruined
and convicted in the of public opinion
before they ever really get a chance to
go through proper legal
process well part of it is you know we
have people that we're that we admire
and that we aspire to be and and
sometimes For Better or Worse they're
often celebrities and we love them but
we kind of hate them too because they're
so annoying because they're better than
us in many ways and that's why we admire
them and so on the one hand we Elevate
them to a status that we probably
shouldn't have elevated them to but on
the other hand we're pretty damn happy
when we can you know fling them to the
ground and Peck off all their feathers
especially if we can do that at no cost
to ourselves and social media um enables
that tremendously because you can
generate a mob of accusers and they can
be anonymous and you can do that no time
flat and you can Peck the feathers off
someone and you can walk away feeling
real good about yourself and you can be
happy that you got to express your
resentment bitterness and and Away you
go and of course you sacrifice someone
for doing that but it's not you and and
that's just fine and so we're doing that
Non-Stop and and social media definitely
enables that and that's a huge danger so
social media enables narcissistic
psychopathy and that's not good because
we virtualized the world and we put a
tremendous amount of power in the hands
of narcissistic Psychopaths and so
that's the virtual world and that's the
world we live in to a large degree now
and so the accuser has all the power and
that's a real technical problem as well
as a moral problem and that's what's
happened to Russell now Russell you know
I mean Russell's sexual behavior was
exactly the kind of hedonistic nightmare
that all the radicals and progressives
are rah rah about non-stop except when
it comes to visit them at home let's say
and and he was celebrated for his
womanizing and and he's apologized for
that and he stopped drinking and he
stopped taking cocaine and usually
people who engage in lenus and impulsive
behavior of the sort that's liable to
get you in trouble are extraordinarily
Intoxicated by alcohol at the time of
doing it so the mere fact that he's you
know become sober in recent years and
also attempted to atone for his sins is
a real plus um I think it was n who said
however that just because you're you
think you're done with your past doesn't
mean your past thinks it's done with you
and that's a dreadful statement and
everyone who's alive should you know be
set back on their Heels by the reality
of that but but hey here we are that's
the world we live in and I'm not so sure
that the canc
right I was going to ask you on that but
if it turns out though that these women
are telling the truth and he is and he
is demonstrated to be proven to be a
rapist and sexual assault presumably you
would agree that that is Despicable and
he should be punished for his
crimes well as you said earlier we have
Courts for determining that and what
constitutes the truth especially in
retrospect particularly in the fog of an
alcoholic encounter let's say is not an
easy thing to to Det and that's why you
have to tr trudge so horribly through
the court system to try to make sense
out of it and of course then what we do
as citizens of a democratic and at least
in principal functional Society is
accept the verdict of a court but you
don't do that beforehand and you
certainly don't presume that just
because someone's accused it's time to
strip them and throw them out into the
street and the reason you don't do that
in part is if that becomes the norm it
will
100% come to visit you and your loved
ones
so you know when you when you when you
attribute to someone else the right to
the presumption of innocence and due
process you are simultaneously
absolutely accre to yourself that the
all that that privilege and right and we
have to remember that because we're all
stupid we're all fools we all do stupid
things and so we need careful protection
for our own fragility and foolishness
and presumption of innocence and due
process is part of that protective
protective structure we sacrifice that
at our great Peril even though it's so
enjoyable to do so right did you see the
Barbie
movie not yet not yet I plan to see it
this week I want to see it from what
you've gleaned about it read about it
heard about it it mentions the word
patriarchy I think a dozen times or
something oh yeah there's no doubt the
whole theme of the thing is that you
know you don't really need men any more
women you can have everything you want
without these ghastly people and we need
to completely dismantle the whole
patriarchy and have a have a matriarchy
right where women run everything and
particularly work run beastly men I mean
this this war on the patriarchy what are
your thoughts on
that well I would say the online World
in many ways is a
matriarchy and the reason I would say
that is because the online World enables
female form antisocial Behavior and
females who are antisocial use
reputation savaging bullying and
exclusion to gain their narcissistic
pathway forward there's a very well
documented psychiatric literature on
female antisocial Behavior and the
online world has many of the elements of
a matriarchy and so yeah well there's
the matriarchy for you and I mean I'm
not saying it would be worse or better
than the patriarchy although I you know
the patriarchy is it's a foolish concept
to begin with because it's such a
radical
oversimplification but um the the idea
that if we just replaced a hierarchy of
men with a hierarchy of women or no
hierarchy at all I mean if you think
that you're so foolish that you should
be put in University and educated by
people who know what they're talking
about of course we can't do that in the
universities anymore either so you know
I think the most ridiculous I started a
new University with my daughter I
remember one recent case it was a
professor who for 25 years had given a
lecture in the use of offensive language
and as part of the lecture he used
offensive language and he got cancelled
for using offensive language and at that
point I realized that parody was dead
right everything was dead I mean in that
moment you couldn't Parry the that that
a professor teaching how to use
offensive language using examples of
offensive language then is deemed to
have offended students so much that he
has to get canceled and lose his job I
mean completely
insane yeah well welcome to the land
ruled by the evil evil clown you know
that that he has ascendence so to speak
when as you pointed out you can't parody
it it's gone to the point where it it's
its own parody and I see that happening
all over and and part of the way you
deal with that and I mean this most
seriously is you deal with that with a
with a positive sense of humor and I can
do that when I'm not ill and I'm feeling
much better even than I did last year
when we were talking and so I can handle
it with a bit of a sense of humor now
and you need to do that um if you lose
your sense of humor
in some ways you've been defeated if you
lose your I completely agree and if if
we don't continue to laugh then these
joyless soulless woke Wass win because
they are joyless they don't laugh at
anything they they are offended by Absol
they comedians they they find comedy
offensive well the moment people find
comedy offensive I find them so
offensive I want nothing to do with
them you well you can tell the tyrants
they hate two things
they hate Comedians and they hate
[Laughter]
cars that's so
[Music]
true good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King Q I think there only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying he's
mocked your weight Trump yeah look at
him fail St working just cuz they're
skin folk don't mean they're kin folk do
you believe you can win this war they
making me cry again they're trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award
winning Lucy Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about that he wants NHS manages
to be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what 7 years down the
line I mean it's it's completely
ludicrous he was clearly something of
the face of the ward so was even more
Unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she' out
the door when they first got together
there were press stories weighty Katy
that would make her a better princess of
wealth cuz you're not just marrying the
man you're marrying the job that
resonates with people gay Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time he wish I'd never met him the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes lab
29 the can we did he say yes I have
taken drugs and they bent the rules or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it there needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and may God Rest their
souls
[Music]
Let It
Roll if we sto producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off chart and
this some of them they're easily
L you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much
very nice of you Twitter you sons of can
you please reinstate my account thank
you there's a threat that you'd be
worried of it so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jurry I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
you be
concerned if it's on your your mind it's
on talk TV it's about you and your
opinions if you're thinking about it
we're talking about
it it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke this is talk
TV welcome back to an uncensor special
with Dr Jordan Peterson next up the
biggest question
of them
all I want to talk to you about your
your new book we who wrestle with God a
lot of your fans there's all sorts of
Jordan Peterson groups that you can join
who debate whether you really believe in
God or not so let's just get it on the
table do you believe in
God I don't think that's any of I don't
think that's anybody's business I think
it's the most private question you can
ask someone but then I would say also uh
what's the right response to that by
their fruits you will know them how's
that well let me ask you a different let
me ask you a different question then do
you do you think there is a
God I'm terrified that there might be
Pierce how's that and I you know I'm not
trying to be a smartass when I'm making
that comment either like they say it's
an old it's an Old Testament saying I
believe that the fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom and that's actually
that is actually about as true a
statement as you could manage in such a
short phrase and you know people have
congratulated me I was at the Buckley
Institute last night they were
congratulating me on my courage and I
think and I said this last night it's
like you guys don't understand it has
nothing to do with courage I'm just
afraid of different things than the
people who lie and I'm afraid for
example of what happens when you lose
control of your tongue and I said that
back in 2016 when I first opposed the
Canadian government and people were you
know congratulating me it's like well
you're so brave to stand up to the
government it's like I'm nowhere near
near as afraid of the government as I am
of what happens when people lose control
over their tongue I studied
totalitarianism for well since I was 13
years old in depth and I know what
happens when people lose control of
their tongue what happens is everything
goes to hell and I don't mean I mean
that metaphysically I might even mean it
theologically but you can just say don't
even bother with that but what's
fascinating let just mean it practically
but what's interesting is I completely
agree with you by the way um and you are
the most open book of almost anyone I've
ever interviewed right to the point I
asked you if you believe in God I didn't
actually know what you were going to say
but for some reason you're reluctant to
say why are you reluctant well okay
let's let let's walk along there well
because it's a it's not a it's not a
well-posed question it's too complicated
an issue to be dealt with like that you
step into instant traps just by
accepting the question so
I I'll show you what I mean so the first
thing I would say is what do you mean by
believe like do you think that a
statement about the existence of God is
something like a scientific theory do
you think it's a list of facts is it a
factual question does God exist or not
is it a factual question like you're
asking about whether a cup on a table
exists or a plate on a table at artifact
in a room what do you mean by this what
do you mean by Bel I'll stake my life on
the proposition that God exists how's
that well is that an answer that's the
right answer I would ask you is my
supplementary do you ever
pray always who do you pray
to the spirit that protects you from
hell but that many people would say is
God hey sounds good to me and so you
might say well I said I pray always so
what does that
mean I'm trying to say the most the
clearest words I can say and I do that
by paying attention I'm listening to the
words and feeling them as I move along
thinking is that a firm foundation in
the moras is that a is that a bridge
over the abyss is that word the right
word I do that when I'm writing I do
that when I'm talking and I do that
because I don't want to be in the
abyss and the pathway over the abyss is
the truth now with regards to belief in
God you might say and I know I know that
that you're not particularly religiously
inclined at least that's the theory it's
like well you have a character Pierce
everyone has a character you could say
that would be the spirit of Pierce
Morgan and then we might say well let's
inquire into that Spirit if you were a
hedonist then the spirit that would be
Pierce Morgan would be your hedonistic
whims and that would be your God I would
say if you're a noble person then your
spirit is something elevated above your
mere whims and then there the spirit
that's inculcated within you it's a
consequence perhaps of your
socialization but in a more
sophisticated way it's actually a
consequence of the spirit that you've
allowed as a consequence of your choices
to dwell within you and that Spirit has
a nature it might be aligned with the
truth might be aligned with falsehood if
it's aligned with the truth it's a
manifestation of what has been
considered traditionally the
logos the more you're aligned with the
truth the more your spirit is an avatar
of the logos that's just it's true it's
religiously true as it turns out but
it's also technically true it's
technically true see I had aate so I'm
going I'm making that case in the new
book right so I did a debate with
Richard Dawkins about this uh who was a
bit disingenuous for me because he sat
with me for a whole show seemed to enjoy
it thank me very much for it and then
called me a fool afterwards in some
podcast so I know you've had a few
Runnings with him and it and it doesn't
surprise me but uh what I said to
Dawkins was because I was raised a
Catholic I was given spiritual guidance
for several years by Catholic nuns and I
do believe in God and the reason I said
to him is that no human brain can really
explain to me or anybody what was there
before before nothing so if you believe
in a Big Bang three what was there
before that because I don't think any
human brain has that power to to explain
or answer that question to me it makes
perfect sense there should be some being
entity something which is superior to a
human brain and I'm I would think that
someone with your brain would think that
too because there are questions we
simply can't answer
okay okay three things about that so the
first is that's the argument by design
that things are so complex and
sophisticated that that cries out for
the hypothesis of something like a
Creator I'm not a big fan of the
argument by Design I can see its
advantages but it isn't the primary
argument as far as I'm concerned so the
the Big Bang proponents have a problem
because it's a tenant of the big bang
theory that the laws of physics
themselves break down at the point of
the singularity and that would be the
point just before the Big Bang and when
you say the laws of physics the
existence of space and time even is an
unknowable prior to the Big Bang you're
basically positing a miracle at the
beginning of existence and so if you get
to have your miracle there's no reason
the religious types can't have theirs
you might argue about what the miracle
needs to be and I think that's an
argument that has to be had I don't like
the argument by Design I like the
argument by conscience better so the
argument by conscience which is another
string of classic theological thought is
that something dwells within you that
aligns you with the spirit of reality
and it's the still Small Voice Within
that was identified first by the the
Prophet Elijah and it was part of a
transformation in the religious
Viewpoint in historical terms that moved
the notion of God from something like
Bal b a b a b a a l a nature God the god
of Storms and earthquakes of of of what
would you say remarkable and a inspiring
natural phenomena to the voice within
that can if you attend to it align you
with the structure of reality itself
that internal voice being a manifest
ation of God and I think that's an
extremely powerful argument and I think
it's right and I'll tell you something
about Dawkins work that's very
interesting so Dawkins has pointed out
that an organism has to be a microcosm
of its environment in order to survive
and I would say the con the voice of
conscience within us is the most uniring
manifestation of the microcosm within
and I think you can make an
extraordinarily powerful biological case
for that and I've done that in this new
book so I think Dawkins argument I think
Dawkins argument invalidates his his
epistemology yeah I agree I really
believe that but what do you think I
mean you you've had moments in your life
in recent years where I would imagine
you have faced the prospect of
potentially dying and in those moments
in those moments what have you felt and
what do you think happens to you if you
do die or you had died what what did you
imagine might happen to
you well at the I had lots of moments
moments years in the last few years
where dying would have been an absolute
relief and had that been accompanied by
the complete cessation of my being I
would have been perfectly content with
that there are things that are far worse
than dying so if you're only terrified
of dying you've hardly begun to plumb
the depths of existential catastrophe
death death is fair you just don't have
an imagination could be worse than
dying being a prison guard at
owitz but You' still be alive even if
you witnessing horror it's not death the
ultimate no I'm thinking perpetrating
it right you mean how about how about
being an oswit guard how about being an
oswit guard who really enjoyed his
job how about that that's worse than
death as far as I'm concerned right I
mean that no no I I see that that's hell
man yeah it's a living hell I agree
that's hell yeah I agree mhm but do you
think there is do you think there's an
actual hell Jordan is there is there
somewhere that people like that go to
which is
hell oh definitely now what what
relationship that has to what happens to
you when you die I have no idea I mean I
don't think anybody's in a position to
speak about what's truly beyond our Ken
let's say I don't think we understand
Consciousness at all we don't understand
time we don't understand the
relationship between finitude and in and
and and the infinite landscape that
surrounds us that's all a great mystery
and I tend to leave that alone because I
try not to speak about things that I
can't speak about but does Hell exist
it's like study history and see if you
can figure it out for yourself I mean
does heaven exist there's nothing
there's nothing that's more obvious than
that hell exists does heaven exist Ma's
China was hell right but does so you're
talking about hell on Earth but do you
believe there's a
hell after
death like I said I I I can't I can't I
don't speculate about such things I
don't that's where my ignorance Finds
Its what would you say that's where my
knowledge Finds Its limit I'm I'm
concerned enough about what I'm doing
right now right here and and leaving the
rest of that and you know I'm so I have
to leave it at that the hell that I see
as a potential on Earth is sufficient as
a deterrent and it's of sufficient
reality you know you can ask well is it
Eternal well I would say well look all
totalitarian states are variance on a
theme let's say and that theme persists
all archetypal stories are Eternal
everything that happened in the Bible
happened and is happening and will
continue to happen forever it's part of
the Eternal human story it's hyper real
and and Heaven and Hell are part of that
what that means in the final analysis I
don't know I mean you asked I think you
asked in there you know hell is real is
heaven real it's like well Heaven is as
far away from hell as you can get that's
a good way of thinking about it um I've
spent my whole life trying to determine
how you get as far away from being a
campg guard at owitz who enjoys his job
as possible and one of the things one of
the things I've realized in recent years
for example is that you are far from
that if you're engaging in your
interactions with the world in the
spirit of voluntary play you know and
we're playing during this conversation
and Joe Rogan plays on his podcast all
the time and if you're in a playful
state with your wife your marriage is
optimized and the state of play is the
opposite of tyranny and that's why it
says in the gospels that if you want to
enter the Kingdom of Heaven you have to
become like a little child so you want
to reinstate that that open eyed
wide-eyed acceptance of life that is the
precursor to voluntary play you want to
develop your character to the point
where that's part and parcel of your
life on an ongoing basis and that's
allowing that Spirit of the logos to
inhabit you that's another way of
thinking about it and you can you can
certainly Aid that with prayer you know
people don't understand people think of
God as the joke is a cosmic Butler you
pray to have your wishes granted it's
like he's not a genie you want to PR you
want to pray it's like pray about your
stupidity here's a prayer that'll work
for sure you want to see if prayer Works
here's one this will work sit on the
edge of your bed ask
yourself what bloody stupid thing do I
continue to do that's making my life
more miserable than it has to be and
everyone else's life around me that I
could give up that I would give up and
but you have to really want the answer
so you open yourself up in humility to a
revelation you'll get an answer it won't
be one you want that's how you'll know
it's true but if you act on it then your
life will improve and that's a proper
prayer yeah that's that's what you do
like in a metaphysical sense the
Christian insistence that you should be
aware of your sins you know which is in
sense in a sense an existential burden
is also the idea that you should attend
to your own inadequacies and admit to
them because in doing so you open up the
possibility that something better can
make itself manifest within you and
there's no doubt that that's the case
that's for sure that's true but you have
to do it in humility and you have to be
looking that's why you're supposed to
take the moat out of your own eye
instead of worrying about the beam in
your neighbor's eye it's like there's
something about you that's stupid you
could fix and God will tell you what it
is if you want him to so do
speak on sus the next to Quick fire
around Jordan Peterson unloads wisdom on
some decidedly practical matters
including how often should we be having
sex good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King Q I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying he mo
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
not working just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this war making me
cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betray keep it
awardwinning Lucy Ley will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Ley wants NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what 7
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the world so
even more unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of wealth cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we lab 29
imagine the can we did he say yes I have
taken drugs and they bent the rules or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it there needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and me God
Souls Let It
[Music]
Roll if we stop producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off show
this some of them they're easily
lit you can kiss my American
yeah thank you very much very nice of
you Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jurry I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
we be concern
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV is
about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about
it it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke welcome back to the final part of
my one woman and Jordan Peterson next I
wanted to set the famous psychologist
some practical philosophical
poses I want to end this part of the of
the interview just with you draw before
we bring your daughter in um my team
were curious whether you would be able
actually physically able to answer
questions with just onew answers because
you think about things on such a high
intellectual plane you're very
articulate you're very thoughtful about
them so I just want to throw a few
questions at and just see whether you
can I'm not saying you have to I'm just
saying can you something straight
forward something a little bit more
complex but what's one piece of music we
should all Listen to Hank
Williams which which song any of them
Lovick
Blues well the supplementary is why
plaintive
truth perfect can money make you happy
yes not by itself right but having money
would make you more happy than than not
having
money
having money and opportunity are very
similar and if you're wise having more
opportunity can be
better how many hours of sleep is
Optimum for the human mind to work
properly it seems that the the about
eight by the looks of
things is marriage good for you uh
compared to the
alternative is owning a pet a good
idea Definitely dog or not pugs though
dogs or cats because I I find that cats
not pugs anything but a pug I've had two
I love pugs I've had two cats for two
cats for about 10 months my first pet
since I was a teenager and I find them
to be utter charlatans like whoever
gives the most affection gets gets them
whereas my family who have dogs they
they're very affectionate to everybody
they're not disloyal like the
cats I I I like dogs and cats but I
prefer cats because they bite you now
and then when you don't expect it and I
think that's I think that's hilarious
they're kind of like women that way how
we talking you women how much sex is
Optimum per week per month well my
experience as a clinician I'll give you
a slightly longer answer to this um my
experience as a clinician is that people
who are married need to communicate
about the the daily their daily issues
for about 90 minutes a week and they
need to spend at least two they need to
have two a week minimum to to sustain
their relationship across time now you
know it varies with the couple obviously
but that's 90 minutes of businesslike
communication to set the to set
everything straight and to keep you
updated with your partner and then you
have to spend you have to have two dates
a week to keep the romance in your life
alive and it's really really really
important to do that and you can do that
but you have to work at it and by dates
are you including sex so twice a week is
Optimum depends on how the date goes man
you should know
that should people go to therapy or can
it really screw you
up depends on the therapist and why they
go it can be very very helpful um
there's no real difference between a
therapeutic relationship and a genuine
relationship and so the question really
is are genuine relationships beneficial
to people and the answer to that is of
course and you might say well can you
mimic a genuine relationship in a
therapy practice and the answer is yes
it it's not as good as a marriage if
it's a good marriage it's maybe not even
as good as a great friendship but if you
lack both of those then a Therapeutic
Alliance can be extraordinarily helpful
now if your therapist is in cautious and
poorly trained and foolish and
ideologically
addled um then it can be a complete
bloody nightmare but everything's like
that right if you go to a surgeon who
doesn't know what he's doing well yeah
you know he'll cut off the wrong leg and
that's often not a good
thing who is the one philosopher we
should all read nature what breakfast
lunch or dinner what's the most
important meal of the day breakfast and
Abram mccraven I if you ever saw this
speech gave a fantastic speech with one
of the top uh military guys in the
American Military and it was basically
centered around making your bed that the
very first thing you should do each day
is make your bed because it set a
discipline for your day and a purpose
and got you going what would your y what
would your advice be for the first thing
people should do when they get up open
their
eyes and look around
them it's a good thing to do all day is
open your damn
eyes what see what's right in front of
you well the bad bad making bad making
duplicates the cosmic order by the way
right because you make order out of
chaos and that's a good thing to do when
you first awaken because you're
reenacting the the creation of the world
in a a symbolic
Manner and finally on this part of the
it's a good day way to get your day
going yeah it is the F final part of
this uh section what is the best and
worst thing about being Jordan Peterson
the worst I'm a bit much you might say
I'm sort of running in I'm running in
all directions very rapidly and so that
can be um a bit much it's hard on people
around me I'm a bit much man and what's
the best thing about you the best thing
about being me yeah it's overwhelming
really well the Deep appreciation that
people have for what I've been
doing it's stunning it's it's Soul
destroying but it's amazing is it not
Soul enhancing I mean I feel it when I
do interviews with you the reaction I
get from people just how much you mean
to them I I mean I can imagine it yeah
well that's a bit much you know I mean
look when I go wherever I go it's so
strange because wherever I go it's it's
like I have friends there because I walk
down the street and people wave at me
and you know they call up my name
and it's a bit much it's amazing it's
really something but it's amazing but
it's hard to it's it is it's hard to
it's hard to wrap my head around it it's
very hard to wrap my head around it and
especially because it happened to me you
know when I was well I didn't when I was
older than 50 it's been quite an
adjustment I wouldn't say it's one I've
made and it's an it's an immense
responsibility and I'm not complaining
about that at all I'd be a fool to
complain an ungrateful fool
but it's
um you know it's a strange thing to have
far more than you
could ever
imagine what do you
mean well that's my life I have far more
than I could ever
imagine I didn't think it was possible
I mean you become somebody who in the
later stage of your life yeah you did it
again you got me again God yeah it's
it's very interesting I mean you are you
are an emotional person I know that um
but I think it's also interesting to me
what makes you emotional and in a way
it's similar to why you were emotional
last time I talked to you is that you
are very acutely aware of the influence
you now have over so many millions of
people and I think you feel that
responsibil
profoundly and I think that's what
triggers you an
emotion yeah it's gratitude
yeah it's amaz you know imagine someone
gave you everything you could possibly
imagine and more well that's the
situation I'm
in and do you find it do you find it
overwhelming sometimes
always
yeah I think that's partly what made me
ill
yeah it's an amazing thing Jordan I want
to I can't think of a better segue
actually than to bring in for the next
part of this interview your daughter
Michaela who will have been I'm sure
watching this and knows you better than
anybody so we're going to come back and
have the second part which is two
Petersons for the price of one
terrible thing to inflict on the
[Laughter]
world the full extended interview is
available now on the peers Morgan
uncensored YouTube channel and tomorrow
we're joined by his daughter Michaela
for one of the most fascinating
interviews of the Year father and
daughter both of them hugely influential
until then whatever you're up to keep it
un
sensive
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King PE and King Q I think
there's only room for one king man you
know what I'm saying he's mocked your
weight Trump yeah look at him fail St
working just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk do you believe you
can win this war making me cry again
they trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it awardwinning m Lucy Ley
will die behind bars and a senior Doctor
Who first raised concerns about that he
once NHS manages to be regulated we
needed answers a lot sooner this is what
7 years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the ward so
even more Unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of we cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time oh he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we yes
lab9
the did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls let it roll
Yoo yes